all of germany is one big outbreak the
words of the head of the country's
disease control agency as the country's
leaders scramble to contain surging
infection figures on thursday lawmakers
approved a series of new measures to
battle record covet 19 infections the
health minister is warning that soon
some hospitals would be able to cope
with general emergency care and the army
is preparing to fly patients abroad
some of them spent the week threatening
to veto this law saying it didn't go far
enough but in the end germany's second
chamber representing the states caved in
and with the raise of a hand gave the
new measures their vote of approval
not a moment too soon
across the capital the health minister
issued a sobering update on the bed
shortage in hospitals
we are getting to a point now where we
will have to transfer covet patients not
just within the same region but to other
regions within germany
and quite possibly even abroad to
neighboring countries
beside him the head of the country's
disease control body compared germany to
a vessel on course for collision
it's as if a tanker is approaching a
harbor wall the tanker is moving
although we are steering against it with
full force it will still move on for a
while and it will probably hit the wall
with the side but hopefully not the
front
the warning comes the morning after
angela merkel in what may be one of her
last acts as chancellor rallied state
leaders to agree on new rules and called
on them to use them
the situation is highly dramatic and it
will be very important that action is
taken quickly the action is consistent
and that it is enforced better
on friday bavaria became the first state
to invoke the new rules announcing that
bars clubs and christmas markets would
be shut for at least three weeks
as well as contact restrictions on those
who haven't been vaccinated
for a long time we've taken care of the
unvaccinated now we have to take less
care of those who do not care at all
this is not fun it's one of the hardest
things to decide but it's necessary
it becomes the first german state to
restrict the private lives of the
unvaccinated
the latest effort to try and ramp up the
pressure on people to get the shot
and i am joined now by robert he is a
senior physician in charge of the
emergency room at leipzig university's
teaching hospital leipzig is in saxony
that's germany's worst hit region uh
well but uh welcome to dw and thanks for
your valuable time you are
on the medical front line in this
pandemic it must be a huge challenge
first how are you and your staff dealing
with the situation
yeah good evening and thanks for
invitation
um
we have like
growing accounts of growing amounts of
patients and we are like having um
lots of care for them and um
also there's the regular patients we
always have in our emergency department
and so this is a big struggle for us
right now
and the accounts are growing and we see
a lot of problems coming in front of us
within the next two weeks
are some staff getting ill despite the
vaccination
um yes we got like our stuff is
vaccinated uh approximately and the
doctors are like 99 vaccinated and the
nurses are like 90 vaccinated but we
started vaccination in uh january
february
and they start losing the immunization
or the immunity and
um
we are about to lose like two to five
nurses a day right now
due to karen dying due to their kids
which are in keratin and this is
also a big problem for us right now
how is that affecting care or are you
having to turn patients away
and not yet we are like doubling the
counts of beds and within that last
week we doubled the the capacity of our
hospital and all the hospitals around
lexi doubled the capacity
uh but actually
we are flying on site we got like
capacity for the next five to six days
and we have to decide later
what other resources we can
manage but also there's a real problem
to transfer patients in other regions
because like the ground-based rescue
service also has like has 20 to 25
percent loss of personal
doctor i hope you'll forgive me when i
ask you this question i we haven't met
before but
it sounds as if you are feeling the
stress even now would that be fair to
say
yes
true
we've we've been seeing it coming within
the last three to four weeks and we've
seen the growing amounts of patients and
it started like one patient a week and
then it's two patients a week and then
it's one patient a day and now we have
like five to six patients a day coming
to a hospital
and and it's still growing
i mean you are in you're in the front
lines you're a medical professional and
yet i wonder whether sometimes you say
to yourself
this is what
might have been happening over a year
ago we're two years into this almost and
it feels almost like day one another
avalanche of patients
yes this is
we we hadn't we had not seen it coming
in that way we had we we trusted you our
immunity but we didn't realize that we
need to boost the right earlier than we
did we started boostering a little late
and
we are now in the middle of boostering
um and but what we actually see in
saxony is that all the people that are
not vaccinated could not be reached yet
and we have like incidences by in an
unvaccinated population around 2000 and
in vaccinated
population around 50.
so this is this is i think the major
problem we have to reach the
unvaccinated people
germany's politicians have announced new
measures will they be enough
i'm not sure yet um they will like
they will fix the problem
maybe in two weeks or three weeks but we
are not sure yet how to come over the
next two weeks as i told you we have
like beds
sure and safe for the next four to five
days and we will see afterwards if it's
getting better a little bit and if it's
getting a little constant to the
constant because we like some people are
healing faster than in the last waves
and
we have to see
we are flying one side
that is uh robert shaw senior physician
at the emergency department of leipzig
university's teaching hospital uh best
of luck and uh hang in there sir
thank you
you